In the last video, we talk
about how seasons on Earth
are not caused by
how close Earth
is to the sun in its orbit.
And we also hint at the
fact that it's actually
caused by the tilt of the earth.
And so in this video,
I want to show you
how the tilt of the earth
causes the seasons to happen.
So let's draw-- so
I'm going to try
to draw as many diagrams
as possible here.
Because at least
for my brain they
help me visualize what's
actually going on.
So we could imagine
a top view first.
So let's have a top view.
That is the sun
right over there.
And let me draw
the earth's orbit.
So Earth's orbit maybe
looks something like that.
Let me draw it almost,
it is almost circular.
So I'll draw it as
something that's
pretty close to a
circle right over here.
And I'm going to draw Earth at
different points in its orbit.
And I'm going to try
to depict the tilt
of its rotational axis.
And obviously, this is not drawn
anywhere near close to scale.
Earth is much further
away from the sun,
and much, much smaller
than the sun as well.
So I'll draw the
earth at that point.
And at this point,
the earth will
be tilted away from the sun.
So Earth's tilt does
not change if you
think about the
direction, or at least
over the course of
a year, if we think
about relatively
small periods of time.
It does not change
relative to the direction
that it's pointing
at in the universe.
And we'll talk about
that in a second.
So let's say right over here we
are pointed away from the sun.
So we're up and
out of this page.
So if I wanted to put some
perspective on an arrow
it would be up and-- actually
it would be more like
up and out of this page.
So that's the direction.
If you were to come straight
out of the North Pole.
And if you were to go
straight out of the South Pole
you'd go below that
circle right over there.
And if I wanted to
draw the same position,
but if we're looking
sideways along the plane,
the orbital plane, or the
plane of Earth's orbit.
So if we're looking at
it from that direction.
So let me do it this way.
If we're looking at
directly sideways,
this is the sun right
over here, and this
is Earth at that position.
This is Earth right over there.
If I were to draw an arrow
pointing straight out
of the North Pole it would
look something like this.
So this arrow and
this arrow they
are both popping straight
out of the North Pole.
And so when we talk about
the tilt of the earth,
we're talking about the
tilt of its orbital axis,
kind of this pole that could
go straight between the South
Pole and the North Pole.
The angle between that and
a pole that would actually
be at a 90-degree
angle, or perpendicular,
to the plane of its orbit.
And so compared to if it was
just straight up and down,
relative to the
plane of the orbit.
So this right here is the
angle of Earth's tilt.
Let me draw that a
little bit bigger
just so it becomes a
little bit clearer.
So if this is the
plane of the orbit,
we're looking sideways along
the plane of the orbit.
And this is Earth
right over here.
My best attempt
to draw a circle.
That is Earth.
Earth does not rotate.
Its axis of rotation is not
perpendicular to the plane
of the orbit.
So this is how
Earth would orbit.
This is how Earth
would rotate if it was.
Earth rotates, Earth's
rotational axis
is at an angle to
that vertical relative
to the plane of its orbit,
I guess you could say it.
It rotates at an
angle like this.
So this would be the North Pole.
That is the South Pole.
And so it rotates like this.
And that angle relative to
being vertical with respect
to the orbital plane, this
angle right here for Earth
right now is 23.4 degrees.
And if we're talking about
relatively short periods
of time, like our
lifespans, that is constant.
But it is actually changing
over long periods of time.
That is changing between--
and these are rough numbers--
it is changing between 22.1
degrees and 24.5 degrees,
if my sources are correct.
But that gives a rough estimate
of what it's changing between.
But I want to make
it clear, this
is not happening overnight.
The period to go from roughly
a 22-degree angle to a 24
and 1/2-degree angle and back
to a 22-degree angle is 41,000
years.
And this long-term
change in the tilt, this
might play into some of the
long-term climactic change.
Maybe it might
contribute, on some level,
to some of the ice ages that
have formed over Earth's past.
But for the sake of thinking
about our annual seasons
you don't have to
worry too much,
or you don't have to
worry at all really
about this variation.
You really just have to
know that it is tilted.
And right now it is tilted
at an angle of 23.4 degrees.
Now you might say OK, I
understand what the tilt is.
But how does that
change the seasons
in either the Northern or
that Southern Hemisphere?
And to do that, I'm going
to imagine the earth when
the Northern Hemisphere is
most tilted away from the sun,
and when it is most
tilted towards the sun.
So remember this tilt, the
direction this arrow points
into relative to the
rest of the universe,
if we assume that
this tilt is at 23.4%,
it's not changing
throughout the year.
But depending on where
it is in the orbit
it's either going to be
tilting away from the sun,
as it is in this
example right over here.
Or it will be tilting
towards the sun.
I'll do the towards the
sun in this magenta color,
or it would be tilting
towards the sun.
So six months later when
the earth is over here,
it's going to, relative to
the rest of the universe,
it will be tilted in that same
direction, up out of this page
and to the right.
Just like it was over here.
But now that it's on the
other side of the sun that
makes it tilt a little
bit more towards the sun.
If I were to draw
it right over here,
it is now tilted
towards the sun.
And what I want to think
about is how much sunlight
will different parts
of the planet receive.
And I'll focus on the
Northern Hemisphere.
But you can make
a similar argument
for the Southern Hemisphere.
I want to think about how much
sunlight they receive when it's
tilted away or tilted
towards the sun.
And so let's think about
those two situations.
So first of all, let's
think about this situation
here where we are tilted
away from the sun.
So let me zoom in a little bit.
So this is the situation, where
we're tilted away from the sun.
So if this is the vertical,
so let me draw it.
I could actually just
use this diagram.
But let me make it.
So we're tilted away
from the sun like this.
I'm going to do this
in a different color.
So if we have an arrow coming
straight out of the North Pole
it would look like this.
And we are rotating
around like that.
So we're out of the page
on the left-hand side,
and then into the page
on the right-hand side.
And so we're rotating
towards the east, constantly.
So this arrow is in the
direction of the east.
So when we're at this point
in Earth's orbit, and actually
let me copy and paste this.
And I'm going to use
the same exact diagram
for the different seasons.
So let me copy.
And then let me paste
this exact diagram.
I'll do it over here for
two different points.
So when we are here
in Earth's orbit
where is the
sunlight coming from?
Well, it's going to be coming
from the left, at least the way
I've drawn the diagram
right over here.
So the sunlight is coming from
the left in this situation.
And so if you think about
it, what part of the earth
is being lit by sunlight?
Or what part of the
earth is in daylight,
the way I've drawn
it right over here?
Well, the part that
is facing the sun.
So all of this right over here
is going to be in daylight.
As we rotate whatever part
of the surface of the earth
enters into this yellow
part right over here
will be in daylight.
But let's think about
what's happening
at different parts of the earth.
So let me draw the equator,
which separates our Northern
and Southern Hemispheres.
So this is the equator.
And then let me go into
the Northern Hemisphere.
And I want to show you why when
the North Pole is pointed away
from the sun why
this is our winter.
So when we're pointed
away from the sun--
Well, if we go to the
Arctic Circle-- so let
me go right over here.
Let me go to some point
in the Arctic Circle.
As it goes, as the earth
rotates every 24 hours,
this point on the globe
will just rotate around just
like that.
It will just keep rotating
around just like that.
And so my question is,
that point in the Arctic
Circle, as it rotates
will it ever see sunlight?
Well, no, it will
never see sunlight.
Because the North Pole is
tilted away from the sun.
So what I'm drawing, what
I'm shading here in purple,
that part of the earth, when
it's completely tilted away,
will never see sunlight.
Or at least it
won't see sunlight
while it's tilted away,
while it's in this position,
or in this position
in the orbit.
I won't say never, because
once it becomes summer
they will be able to see it.
So no sunlight, no day, I guess
you could say, no daylight.
If you go to slightly
more southern latitudes,
so let's say you go over here.
So maybe that's the latitude of
something like, I don't know,
New York or San Francisco
or something like that.
Let's think about what it
would see as the earth rotates
every 24 hours.
So this would be daylight,
daylight, daylight, daylight,
then nighttime, nighttime,
nighttime, nighttime,
nighttime.
This is now going behind the
globe nighttime, nighttime,
nighttime, nighttime, nighttime,
daylight, daylight, daylight,
daylight.
So if you just compare this.
So let me do the
daylight in orange.
And then nighttime I will do
in this bluish purplish color.
So night time over here.
So if you go to really
northern latitudes,
like the Arctic Circle,
they don't get any daylight
when we are tilted
away from the earth.
And if we go to slightly
still northern latitudes,
but not as north as the Arctic
Circle, it does get daylight.
But it gets a lot less daylight.
It spends a lot less
time in the daylight
than in the night time.
So notice if you say that
this circumference represents
the positions over 24 hours,
it spends much less time
in the daylight than it
does in the nighttime.
So because, while the Northern
Hemisphere is tilted away
from the earth, the latitudes
in the northern hemisphere
are getting less daylight.
They are also getting
less energy from the sun.
And so that's what
leads to winter,
or just being generally colder.
And to see what
happens in the summer
let's just go the other side.
So now we're going to the
other side of our orbit
around the sun.
This is going to be
six months later.
And notice the actual
direction, relative to the rest
of the universe,
has not changed.
We're still pointed in
that same direction.
We still have a 23.4 degree
tilt relative to, I guess,
being straight up and down.
But now once we're over
here the light from the sun
is going to be coming
from the right.
Just like that.
And now, if on this
diagram at least,
this is the side
of the earth that
is going to be
getting the sunlight.
And let me draw
the equator again,
or my best attempt
to draw the equator.
I'll draw the equator
in that same color
actually, in that green color.
So this separates the Northern
and the Southern Hemisphere.
And now let's think
about the Arctic Circle.
So let's say I'm sitting
here in the Arctic Circle.
As the day goes on,
as 24 hours go around,
I'll keep rotating around here.
But notice the whole time
I am inside of the sun.
I'm getting no nighttime.
There is no night
in the Arctic Circle
while we are tilted
towards the sun.
And if we still do that
fairly northern latitude,
but not as far as
the Arctic Circle,
maybe in San Francisco or New
York, or something like that .
If we go to that latitude,
notice how much time
we spend in the sun.
So maybe we just enter.
So this is right at sunrise.
And then as the
day goes on we're
in sunlight, sunlight, sunlight,
sunlight, sunlight, sunlight,
sunlight, sunlight.
Then we hit sunset.
Then we hit
nighttime, nighttime,
then we hit nighttime, and
then we get sunrise again.
And so when you look
at the amount of time
that something in the
Northern Hemisphere
spends in the daylight
versus sunlight,
you'll see it spends a lot
more time in the daylight when
the Northern Hemisphere
is tilted towards the sun.
So this is more day, less night.
So it is getting more
energy from the sun.
So when it is tilted
towards the sun
it is getting more
energy from the sun.
So things will
generally be warmer.
And so you are now
talking about summer
in the Northern Hemisphere.
And the arguments for
the Southern Hemisphere
are identical.
You could even play
it right over here.
When the Northern Hemisphere
is tilted away from the sun,
then the Southern Hemisphere
is tilted towards the sun.
And so for example,
the South Pole
will have all daylight
and no nighttime.
And southern latitudes will have
more daylight than nighttime.
And so the south
will have summer.
So this is summer in the south,
in the Southern Hemisphere.
And it's winter in the north.
And then down here the
Southern Hemisphere
is pointed away from the sun.
So this is winter in
the Southern Hemisphere.
And you might be saying, hey
Sal, what about you haven't
talked a lot about
spring and fall.
Well let's think about it.
Well, if we're talking about
the Northern Hemisphere,
this over here, we
decided, was winter
in the Northern Hemisphere.
And we're going to
rotate around the sun.
And at some point, we're
going to get over here.
And then because of
this tilt we aren't
pointed away or towards the sun.
We're kind of pointed
I guess sideways
relative to the
direction of the sun.
But this doesn't favor one
hemisphere over the other.
So when we're over here
in-- and this will actually
be the spring now- when
we're in the spring,
both hemispheres are getting
the equal amount of daylight
and sunlight, or
for a given latitude
above or below the
equator, they're
getting the same amount.
And the same thing
is true over here
when we get to--
so this is spring.
This is the summer in
the Northern Hemisphere.
Now this will be the fall
in the Northern Hemisphere.
And once again, we're
tilted in this direction.
And so the Northern
Hemisphere isn't
tilted away or towards the sun.
And so both
hemispheres are going
to get the same amount of
radiation from the sun.
So you really see the extremes
in the winters and the summers.
Now one thing I do
want to make clear,
and I started off with just the
length of day and nighttime.
Because frankly, that's maybe
a little bit, or at least
in my brain, a little
bit easier to visualize.
But that by itself
does not account
for all of the difference
between summer and winter.
Another cause, and actually this
is probably the biggest cause,
is if you think about
the total amount of sun.
So let's talk about the
Northern Hemisphere winter.
And let's say there's a
certain amount of sunlight
that is reaching the earth.
So this is the total
amount of sunlight
that's reaching the earth
at any point in time.
You see that much more of
that is hitting the Southern
Hemisphere than the
Northern Hemisphere here.
All of these, if
you imagine it, all
of these rays
right over here are
hitting the Southern Hemisphere.
So a majority of the rays
are hitting the Southern
Hemisphere.
And much fewer are hitting
the Northern Hemisphere.
So actually a smaller amount
of the radiation period,
at even a given period
in time, not even talking
about the amount of time
you are facing the sun.
But at any given moment
in time more energy
is hitting the Southern
Hemisphere than the Northern.
And the opposite is true
when the tilt is then
towards the sun.
And now a disproportionate
amount of the sun's energy
is hitting the
Northern Hemisphere.
So if you draw a
bunch of, if you just
think that this is all of
the energy from the sun, most
of it, all of
these rays up here,
are hitting the
Northern Hemisphere.
And only these down here
are hitting the Southern
Hemisphere.
And on top of that, what
makes it even more extreme
is that the actual angle, and of
course, this is to some degree
is due to the fact that
where the angle of the sun
relative to the horizon,
or where you are on Earth.
But even more than
that if you are on,
let's say that this
is the land, and we're
talking about the winter
in the Northern Hemisphere.
So let's say you're
talking about,
let's say we're up over here
at this northern latitude.
And we're just looking
at the sun here.
And over here,
you could see even
when we are closest to the
sun the sun is not directly
overhead.
When we're closest
to the sun the sun
still is pretty
low on the horizon.
So it may be right
over here when
we're closest to the sun
in the winter the sun might
be right over here.
But if you look at that
same latitude in the summer
when it is closest
to the sun, the sun
is more close to being
directly overhead.
It still won't be
Because we are still at a
relatively northern latitude.
But the sun is going to
be much higher in the sky.
And these are all
related to each other.
It's kind of connected
with this idea
that more energy is hitting
one hemisphere or the other.
But also, when you
have a, I guess
you could say, a steeper
angle from the rays
of the sun with the
earth, it's actually
going to be dissipated
less by the atmosphere.
And let me just make
it clear how this is.
So in the summer-- so let's
say that that's the land.
And let's say that-- let me
draw the atmosphere in white--
so all of this area right over
here, this is the atmosphere.
And obviously there's not a hard
boundary for the atmosphere.
But let's just say this is the
densest part of the atmosphere.
In the summer, when the
sun is higher in the sky,
the rays from the sun are
dissipated by less atmosphere.
So they have to get through
this much atmosphere.
And they're bounced off.
And they heat some
of that atmosphere.
And they're absorbed before
they get to the ground.
In the winter when the
sun is lower in the sky,
so maybe the sun is out here.
Let me draw it a little bit.
So when the sun is lower in
the sky relative to this point,
you see that the
rays of sunlight
have to travel through
a lot more atmosphere.
So they get dissipated
much more before they
get to this point on the planet.
So all in all it
is the tilt that
is causing the
changes in the season.
But it's causing it
for multiple reasons.
One is when you're
tilted, we'll say
when you're tilted
towards the sun,
you're getting more
absolute hours of daylight.
Not only are you getting more
absolute hours of daylight,
but at any given moment, most
or more of the sun's total rays
that are hitting the earth
are hitting the Northern
Hemisphere as opposed to
the Southern Hemisphere.
And the stuff that's hitting
the places that have summer,
it has to go through
less atmosphere.
So it gets dissipated less.